i can't tell you how excited we've all
been uh to meet you this morning and
have you on sky news today so thank you
very much and first off congratulations
thank you european champions how does it
feel yeah it's been a crazy few days um
but one that has been really special and
and one that we'll remember for a long
long time well you you're taking the
country with with you everyone's so
delighted for your victory on sunday and
really so excited to see all your
partying as well and how was that you
look like you're having a great time on
sunday night through to monday morning
yeah we had a great time celebrating
with all our friends and family um
they'd been along this journey with us
for for the whole time and it was nice
and they got to come and join the
celebrations and they're a huge part of
all of our journeys um
so it was nice that they were there has
it sunk in yet
uh
slowly it is yeah it takes definitely
taking a few days um when you switch off
from it all i think that's when it will
really hit you but it's just been an
incredible month i mean i've read that
you actually haven't had time to watch
the match yet watch it back is that
right no not had time yet uh just been
non-stop yeah i bet it has and you've
got to kind of enjoy every moment
haven't you i'm sure you're being told
to do that i mean you were the second
highest goal scorer for england which is
an incredible feat in itself and of
course we have to talk about that goal
that you scored in the semi-finals
against sweden that that back heel goal
i think we can have a look at it now
certainly in a couple of minutes i mean
it's been described as one of the
greatest goals of all time
how does that make you feel
yeah a bit surreal really i don't see it
as that but it's nice that people do i
think it it was um can you talk us
through it yeah it was a bit of an
instinctive goal to be honest
i just remember missing the first chance
and then
figuring that i had to do something
about it and there was a player stood in
front of me so i couldn't turn
and the back here was just the easiest
route to goal and luckily it went in and
you also nutmeg the goalkeeper which is
pretty impressive yeah i didn't know i
did that until after because i didn't
even see it go in let alone how so um so
yeah i saw that one after i mean it's
the type of tricks that you might see in
an exhibition match isn't it or when
you're kind of practicing and you're
mucking around with your teammates
afterwards not not in a semi-final of
the euro 2022 yeah i'm sure i've maybe
done it on the playground when i was a
kid or or in the park with my brothers
but uh not sure i've done it on a stage
like that before so it was really cool
and and i make it it kind of signifies
an awful lot about your team which is i
think you you've been told kind of to do
what you want on the pitch and enjoy
yourself and take those risks and play
with joy and and we really saw that
watching you you all look like you were
having a great time as well as playing
superb football and that's no easy feat
because you did have the pressure of the
country on you did you feel that
i mean we we knew the the importance of
the tournament and obviously to have it
in in england and in front of your home
fans was just unbelievable at wembley
against germany yeah the states don't
get hired i know they don't but at the
same time like
to us it's it's just football like we do
it every day as a kid and and it's what
we love we love stepping on the pitch
and i do think that yeah the crowd's
unbelievable and they were really on our
side but when you're on the pitch it's
just football like it's just what what
you love doing so um
yeah the the media around it all was
great but we were a bit numb to that all
until we we came out and we finished the
tournament and i suppose that's a
testament to your friendships on the
team you all let you get on really well
and of course your relationship with
your manager yeah
it's very strong yeah it was kept very
uh
a tight bubble really and we were just
so focused on performing playing well
getting better that uh
the rest didn't really affect us so i
mean two weeks ago many of us didn't
didn't really know you particularly or
or many of your teammates unless we're
kind of ardent football supporters and
now i mean you're a household name i
mean you've got big big interviews in
the major newspapers today been on many
many tv channels how does that feel
yeah to be honest it's all been a bit
crazy really um
it's all happened so quickly and
it's just yeah it but for me i'm just
celestia like i'm just enjoying this all
i love playing football and i love
playing for england so
it's just off the back of doing
something i love so that's the most
important thing i mean a lot of people
are tipping you as the next emma adikanu
and of course many of your teammates as
well you potentially have an awful lot
of commercial opportunities ahead of you
you've got you know your future is
bright anyway but maybe even brighter
now
how do you feel about that
yeah i i mean would you like those yeah
of course i think it's a huge part and
as a female athlete you are a role model
like uh you have to inspire the young
girls else you're not doing your job
that's what i see
myself off the pitch i just want to
inspire girls to go out there and play
and get involved in football or whatever
sport it may be so
let my football on the on the pitch do
the talking and then off the pitch just
try and encourage and and inspire the
next generation because i know that your
brother lucas is your agent isn't he so
are you i mean are you going to be able
to handle all of this all the fuss and
maybe commercial deals and all that side
of it and also kind of keep playing
great football is that going to be a
tricky
kind of mix to manage
i mean for me football's my priority
none of this would happen without it so
that's all i can focus on playing well
on the pitch and enjoying enjoying every
second of training and getting better as
a player and then the rest everyone else
can deal with not for me
and he yeah i just deal with the
football and you sound like you've got
your feet in the ground i mean you've
got a tight-knit family haven't you
you're offering your holidays tomorrow
so they will keep you grounded yeah
absolutely i think that's a huge credit
to the family that's
yeah
there's no point getting too ahead of
yourself it's it's only the beginning
and we've only we've just won a
tournament and it's amazing but there's
still loads more that that we still want
to achieve let's talk about role models
because you mentioned that yourself i
mean you're an enormous role model um my
my little girl mary who's six years old
was watching on sunday and i you i mean
you've got a huge amount of
power ahead and responsibility how does
that feel to be a role model and also
changing what it is to be
a woman like a woman who doesn't mind
getting money and dirty and being
aggressive and you know it's not the
usual kind of role model of femininity i
certainly grew up with
yeah i think that's what i love about it
it's a bit different
i've always loved sports whether it's
male female football tennis athletics
i've always grown up watching the
olympics watching everything so
they they were role models to me when i
was younger um and now to it feels weird
saying that i'm a role model because i
don't see it like that i just go out and
play on the pitch and the rest will come
but
yeah it's it's nice to hear the like
young girls out there looking up to us
all um
i think we we've had an unbelievable
month of football but long may it
continue we want to carry on on this
journey and
there's a world cup next summer there's
lots of games coming up sooner we've got
uh
the season at manchester united starts
in a few weeks so
yeah i think lots more to do but um
definitely enjoying the moments along
the way and and you're right this is a
moment to capitalize on us and it's not
just you it's all of us have to support
women's football don't we to keep it
keep it in the limelight i know that you
and some other players have written to
both of the conservative leadership
hopefuls liz trust and russia synagogue
asking for all girls to be able to play
football at school and have at least two
hours of pe a week um i mean how hopeful
are you that all girls in this country
will get a chance to play football at
school
yeah it's crazy that it's not even a
thing already i remember that when i was
a kid like i used to
my root into football was through boys
football
which was okay for me but other girls
might want not want to get involved
unless it's a girls team which is
completely understandable and i think
that um
yeah as
we've just achieved something great we
want to achieve something even greater
and and help push this for the for the
young girls out there who want to get
involved in football but feel like they
can't
have you heard back from them
i'm not too sure i've been so busy today
um but yeah a lotta one of the girls on
the team kind of came up with the
initiative and everyone got on board so
quickly like that so
yeah she she was
the the start of it and
what a fantastic idea i know that liz
trust was watching wasn't she at wembley
or on sundays so you never know um what
can what do you want everyone else to be
doing what do you want the industry to
be doing to to promote for example the
women's super league and to promote more
girls getting into football what's their
job now i just done the hard bit yeah i
just think like having the availability
um and i know it is easier said than
done it there's obviously a lot
going on behind the scenes that has to
put that in place but i mean why not
like for the young girls that were
throughout the tournament it's kind of
nice for them to actually see
women
pack a stadium out and
to be honest if you can't see it you you
can't be it so
that's a really important message from
us throughout this tournament so uh more
more bums on seats bigger stadium more
access on tv with that all that kind of
yeah and it is going in the right
direction it's been going in the right
direction for a while now and and credit
to everyone behind the scenes pushing
for it um we we see it and and we just
as players now need to continue that
path so i know that you're offering
holidays soon but you're not going to
have that much of a break are you
because i know you're going to be
training but for your your obviously
count backer to manchester united and
then of course in september you've got
the small matter of qualifications for
the world cup yeah how are you feeling
about that
yeah it's an exciting time i think with
sports you you can enjoy a moment um one
so special like the euros but within a
couple weeks you got something else
knocking on the door so um yeah really
excited to get back to manchester united
and and play the season and then yeah
international breaks along the way
hopefully with should we be talking
about winning the world cup i mean is
that something that you welcome do you
fancy your chances
i mean there's still a long way to go
yeah but um
yeah it was a great tournament and we
put on some fantastic performances and
the girls and the com the
competitiveness of the squad is just sky
high and the league as well um the top
team that's just
stacked with top players and
yeah it is going to do exciting time
it's an exciting time yeah we'll see
and finally where are you going to keep
your medal
i don't know i need to figure this one
out um we didn't get a little box or
anything so and i'm very clumsy and a
bit forgetful so i need to put it
somewhere safe maybe use it whatever you
do you have to find a good place in the
bedroom michelle i'm sure it's going to
be there amongst many many other uh
trophies to come maybe even the world
cup who knows alyssia it's been an
absolute pleasure to meet you thanks so
much for coming on and best of luck